i kind of get the feeling that peter
might actually be attempting to flip
back and forth between mj knowing who he
is and also forgetting that's great for
any guy in her relationship
she's mad at me flip
huh who are you
you want to go out you're cute all right
just back into me flip back on
[Music]
what's happening there reject nation
greg and john here hope you enjoyed our
spider-man no way home trailer reaction
if you haven't seen that it's up now
thank you to everyone who appeared in
the opening sketch one of them being
heavy spoilers who has merch and i made
sure to rock it for this specific video
so he did a spider-man no way home
trailer breakdown probably the first one
up dang with easter eggs and all that
jazz in here you know it's gonna be good
let's see what's in store welcome to the
heavy spoiler show i'm your host paul
aka your friendly neighborhood spoiler
man and spider-man no way the trailer
has been released after 84 years we have
our personal look at the movie and in
this video we're going to be breaking
down the easter eggs things you missed
and discussing all the plot points
finally here man it's been living in my
head rent-free like peter parker and i'm
so hyped to talk about it so let's just
get into it now we start off with peter
and mj sitting on a rooftop this is
something that has happened at several
points in the comics and films and i got
a lot of vibes here of the original
spider-man 3 in which the pair both sat
stargazing we learned that this is in
the aftermath of peter's identity being
made public but looks like at this point
that he's managed to clear his name even
if everyone now knows it mj is reading a
newspaper from the new york post and not
the daily bugle as we learn that in the
mcu it was an alex jones-esque show
rather than a publication i gotta say
like one thing that this trailer
remarkably had me pulled into right away
was the romantic aspect between the two
of them like they they really feel like
they've been it's like they just became
boyfriend and girlfriend they feel like
they've been boyfriend and girlfriend
for a while i've been through so much
together and it does enhance that debate
of like i don't want mj to forget though
yeah exactly on the front cover it reads
peter parker and his spider minions with
him puppeting people showing that the
media is still sort of trashing him even
though he saved the city and also the
universe gonna put some dirt in their
eyes and it also shows that
have been pulled into it too which we'll
talk about later on in the video now mj
reads one of the passages out about how
some suggest parker's powers include the
ability to hypnotize females whilst this
is thrown away as a little joke it
actually foreshadows the big reveal in
the trailer in which peter asks strange
to pretty much hypnotize the entire
world into forgetting that he's
spider-man peter just wants to stay up
there forever and then we cut to him and
mj swinging through the streets of new
york in the aftermath of the
post-credits scene from far from home
peter's face is blown up all over times
square with the mask superimposed onto
one side i know it's like it's so
classic
when his spider sense is set off and
it's also very similar to some of the
promo material which showed his face
split between strangers i really feel
like out of any of the spider-man live
action that we've gotten from the mcu
alone this trailer alone feels the most
like a comic book way more than far from
home and way more than homecoming this
felt feels different this feels like
pages from a wonderful graphic novel
doesn't it yeah absolutely you later see
a shot in which people swamp him at a
subway entrance and judging by the
location of this shot i would say that
this is how the movie opens the street
sign says
which according to google wow
which is where peter was at during the
post crazy in that movie from what we
know of the film the opening is very
much going to be in the same vein as
john wick 3 and it'll see spider-man
being chased across new york as this
revelation breaks the internet we occur
to him in the police station trying to
explain the drones and how they are what
killed mysterio even though he was put
in charge of edith peter also sits with
handcuffs on which reminds me a lot of
man of steel when superman was being
interrogated you know what else is like
man of steel bvs when they're all like
gathered around yeah the superhero in
the dark except this time they're trying
to kill him like richard ramirez they're
not trying to touch him for his glorious
power they're trying to bring him down
because he's a mess and there's a guy
who slams down some papers in a split
second
and it looks a lot like matt murdock
from the shirt to the tie yeah we do
know that charlie cox will be in the
movie and this is a blink and you'll
miss a moment that i'm 99 sure is him
the one percent is because i asked a
mate who said it definitely wasn't him
so tell him to shut the hell up in the
comments if he's wrong because i really
hate the guy for disagreeing with me now
we could to him and mj reading their
phones which clearly have headlines and
reports about the revelation i love how
this and the opening of the trailer are
pretty much them obsessing over the news
reports and it shows how much it being
out there has completely dominated their
lives
wanting to just stay on the roof away
from everyone shows how much he feels
deep down that it's changed things for
the worst and it nicely sets up the
actions that he takes also i love how mj
has sketches of people hanging above her
bed and this is something that she of
course did during detention and
homecoming next we get what is clearly a
flashback in which the character likely
handed himself in or was taken to court
[Music]
and mephisto confirm
[Music]
here he's joined by ned mj and what i
think is flash thompson who has dyed his
hair blonde in the comics the character
was blonde and it's nice to see him
supporting peter flash was obviously a
massive spider-man fan but ironically he
hated peter and also bullied him again
making him feel the most like comics you
know they made tony revelry a white guy
yeah
finally he's got some aryan jeans in it
what's up i'm sorry about the blotting
that also seems like an easy thing to
turn into a bit with flash sure joke the
reveal has obviously changed things and
it will be interesting to see if
reversing this knowledge turns him back
into being a baddie next we cut to what
i believe is immediately after the
events of far from home in which both
peter and mj are getting followed
through new york from here we jump to
him in school and bro i cannot believe
he went back there you know what i know
right idiot myself and i definitely
definitely wouldn't be returning there
mate steer clear actually find it like
hilarious after all that he's like
maybe i should go back to high school
see how things go everybody can still
have a normal life maybe nobody noticed
maybe more penguins you know kids these
days don't pay attention to the news oh
forget about it in five minutes like how
excited a lot of them were yeah they're
seeing a superhero at this point do they
view him as a superhero or a criminal i
don't know maybe he's going to clean out
his locker now we see peter and may sat
in their apartment and from this shot i
almost get the feeling like someone has
walked in on them from the way that she
sits up a pervert
it is new york people he loves and as
batman said the mask is to protect those
around you now this might be pulling
slightly from the civil war comic as
that had peter revealing his identity to
the world in order to show that the
superhuman registration act was
something worth doing peter was very
much the eyes and ears of the reader and
over time he changed his mind and went
on the run his arc actually ended with
ant-may getting shot which plays into
the one more day storyline that we'll
talk about in a bit oh damn is that
going to happen in the movies
led to people around him being put in
danger and it'll be interesting to see
if they lean into what happens with may
in that especially as we don't really
see her in the rest of the trailer you
would think peter spider-tingle would
have gone off hey there's a lot of
issues with that
going in on the couch shot
he's just kind of just sitting there but
if it is like a threat that's incoming
or something like that you know maybe
his spider sense is just really really
dependent on his current student peter
tingles maybe
terminology
all right we haven't he hasn't yet
becomes
that's right that's right that's fair
his peter takes peters
from this trailer we can also confirm
that the film will be spanning a lot of
seasons as we catch peter in a classroom
with halloween decorations hanging up
cut back to when he and mj were sat in
their room and we could see christmas
lights we also know from behind the
scenes videos that peter is gonna be in
the snow at some point so i would say
that this movie takes place over at
least the span of six months judging
from when far from home happened and the
decoration around the sets we're dealing
with like multiverse [ __ ] you know so
six months might not be a real six
months in this time frame that we're
dealing with maybe you're jumping to new
york's in different seasons i think you
should have you know theorized going
there paul in spite of how fast you got
this up dude you're being lazy dropping
the ball you're being really lazy paul
but no it would be cool this time to see
uh peter parker through a bunch of
different seasons like spider-man
through the season a spider-man for all
seasons yeah there you go that's what
every suit is for
this is my winter look here comes up
with the idea to go and see doctor
strange by looking at the hanging wizard
lights that are in the aforementioned
group he journeys to the sanctum
sanctorum which we can see covered in
snow now why this likely is is because
bruce banner blew a big hole in the roof
[Music]
right after this strange was at the very
least snapped away and the fact that it
took a while to get it fixed might
confirm that one was two during this
time one grew hair at that time
shoveling snow but bro thought you could
use magic
set a fireplace on fire bruh just melt
it and do that thing you didn't
just do that with the water i feel like
you really would be not bending the
rules too much just to tidy up
white people's memory of peter parker he
could use some spell to tidy up the snow
in there i mean the cloak could probably
do it you know even like dr strange
looks the most out of a comic book in
this one doesn't he yeah i mean his
whole like his hair and his goatee are
so crisp looking yeah they look pencil
drawn in a strange impea have a nice
little back and forth in which they talk
over what to address each other as this
of course plays on the first time that
they met in which they used their
made-up names strange's mug says for
[ __ ] sake which sort of makes me think
he's thinking that seeing peter show up
on his doorstep anyway the webhead has
one request and that is to remove the
knowledge from everyone's head that
peter parker is spider-man now as
mentioned earlier this is clearly
pulling from the comic book storyline
one more day in which he went to strange
in order to help save aunt may strange
even lived in a run down and boarded up
sanctorum during this and he helped him
to travel through multiple timelines so
that he could see if there was anyone
who could help unfortunately everyone
said that there was nothing they could
do and thus he ended up turning to
mephisto now this idea of traveling
through timelines could potentially be
seen in the trailer as peter asks if he
can go back in time or something and
strange levitates at one point in a
position that looks similar to what he
did in infinity war now if we are right
with this then it clearly doesn't work
as strange has to carry out a different
spell and as endgame showed us all that
travelling back would do would be to
create a branched reality in the comics
no one was able to help peter and he
ended up making a deal with mephisto and
along with bringing mae back he also
removed the knowledge from everyone's
mind that peta was spider-man this was
so that people wouldn't come after me
again and in exchange for doing this
mephisto made it so that peter and mj
never got married and the fact that
strange is the one carrying out the
spell and not the devil who's always in
the details makes me think he won't
actually be showing up in the mcu for a
long time yes i know it was obvious i
just i was just holding out hope that
one of the fan theories would be right
and everything i said in one division
wasn't for nothing well there's
something that seems rather devilish
about the way the doctor trains them
as he does he's the most sus part of the
entire train you'd have to really play
for one more day maybe mephisto's
putting himself in disguise i'm not
saying i believe that but i mean by this
point even so even if it's not doctor
strange i mean clearly you've got the
makings here we've got a spell that's
gonna go horribly orion we're gonna need
somebody else to fix it maybe peter will
get just that exactly now in between
this scene we hear peter explaining to
strange why it's really important that
this happens and amongst the shots of
him getting swamped which we talked
about earlier jump to wong who warns
strange not to cast the spell and he
promises not to even though he gives
peter a cheeky little wink interestingly
wong packs his bags and leaves and from
what we've seen of the shangchi trailer
this might actually be him going off to
fight the abomination kevin feige has
confirmed that he is indeed in the film
i like that we kind of watch him walking
off whilst this happens i mean i guess
that'd be kind of weird chongchi doesn't
make it explicitly clear where it takes
place i don't want to ruin chongqi at
all here yeah yeah
without spoiling anything if all this
multiverse chaos from like the spidey
world is happening the spider-man movie
that would be taking place also
simultaneously within shang chi to which
they don't not gonna say anything about
multiverse per se i will just say that
this looks like it throws things into a
major disarray yes and if that seems to
have no you think there'd be like uh
all right let's just continue
there are a lot of places one could be
going right yeah we watch strange use
one of peter's hairs in the men in black
memory eraser spell clearly something
like this is needed in order to tie your
spell to someone and the character
pinched some hair from thor in ragnarok
before sending him and his brother off
to me oh it's really good getting that
hair
no we talked about this moment in our
last plot league video and it looks like
peter interrupting the spell is what
causes reality to break open he doesn't
want his girlfriend or people like may
to forget he's spider-man and thus he
knocks strange's concentration off
slightly in order to stipulate this
earlier in the trailer peter does say
that he feels bad about lying to mj so
it does make sense why this would
suddenly spring to mind now if toby and
andrew are indeed in the film which yeah
worst kept secret of all time then this
moment could be a call back to the happy
birthday storyline in that dormammu
attacked new york and dr strange cast a
spell which peter interrupted this split
open time itself and he was able to view
a future version of himself as well as a
past one he was able to interact and
change events so we might even see a
moment in which peter stops the
broadcast with mysterio either way this
spell seemingly works but we also get
what looks like a rainbow bridge wait a
minute that that seems to be exactly
what would be it referencing
free look guys we know toby and andrews
we know
toby and andrew and this was quite
playing around all right all you guys
who have already been like i don't think
it's a spider verse but all that
little faith we're right we know toby
and andrew are in there and i think he
hit the nail on the head i haven't
surprisingly heard that brought up yet
that that specific comic and how that
could be the reason why seeing like toby
maguire and andrew garfield borrowing
from that like you have to really hit
the nail on the head there dude i mean
that's blowing my mind how if we haven't
heard that already have we and i just
forgot not in any not in a breakdown
we've seen so far yeah league
speculation you know what no we should
read more doctor strange comics
dr strange
and a few more
trade paperbacks
or we just let paul do it and he
rockstars and everyone else i'm just
excited for tom holland to age into toby
maguire
because it's not the same thing it's
just different version
this effect is typically shown when
someone is traveling through the bifrost
so maybe at this point a villain comes
across the multiverse and into the mcu
it also looks like a doctor strange one
he's in a number of fake fan made
trailers so give yourself a pat on the
back if you did that you spoiled the
trailer and you got it right well done
now there are several villains that i
counted in this first look
at least teasers to them this is
obviously the first look and sony don't
want to blow their load but from what i
saw and what we know of the film the
rumors and reports are true
it's true
all of it
the first big one is of course alfred
molina's doctor octopus
who arrives at the end of the trailer
and says hello peter during one of the
many quick cuts was that that was a
really bad i should have wrote moving on
now molina has pretty much taken the
mantle of the spoiler man from tom
holland and he's been out and about
telling us everything that happens in
the movie according to him we see a
scene in which an alternate version of
the character at the end of spider-man 2
is pulled across the multiverse through
a ball if you catch your mind back to
that film the villain died after
drowning a miniature sun in the hudson
and it's possible that when this
collapsed that it pulled him across
willem defoe's green goblin is also
teased when a pumpkin bomb rolls towards
the screen we've been saying for months
now that he's in the film and that he
will end up forming the sinister six you
also see some electrical sparks and know
from jamie foxx that he will be
reprising his role as electro though his
costume will be different i mean after
watching like so much of a spectacular
spider-man and seeing the way you can
visually realize electro damn that just
from these little tidbits you're like
that's like the electro that i've been
wanting to see and i'm so excited for it
dude justice for elektra yeah seriously
though he does black and gold suit has
been heavily shown in the toys and
promotional material and judging by the
circuitry on it this will be used to
fight the electrical enemy now they may
pull from this they may not but from
what i've been told the majority of the
characters are what if versions in which
their arcs differ slightly so if you
still like the version that makes more
sense
then that isn't going to be
we also see a pile of sand rising up in
the trailer as well as the lizard from
the amazing spider-man 2 jumping up at
peter whilst it's in a glass what's him
yeah we'll be doing some minor spoilers
here just talking about the context of
this shot from what the leaks say i know
some of you don't want to know anything
so if you don't want this ruined then
swing out the video but i promise you
i'll just be providing info on the
scenes and nothing really beyond that as
always take these with a pinch of salt
as they might not come true but the
trailer does like you've been pretty
good so far man
what's up in
trailer chaos across new york whilst he
after
this
tries to figure out a way to send them
back willem dafoe's norman osborne shows
up to ask about their lives and they say
the last thing they remember was
spider-man unable to free them because
of the powerful magic osborne goes to
peter and pleased with him to help out
and he tells him that these characters
will die if they're returned home he
also says that the peter of their world
was there when they passed away and tom
holland's version is wrecked with guilt
because he could potentially be sending
them back to their deaths so he breaks
into strange's prison and steals a
magical cube that's holding them in
place we see this in the trailer and
strange supposedly chases peter across
new york in the mirror dimensions
inception the effect of course appeared
in the first doctor strange movie and
it's gonna make for an amazing scene
okay well visually because when i first
heard
we heard that like plot description a
long time ago peter would break them out
and i didn't like the way that was
sounding that just kind of made me
annoyed at the thought of peter breaking
them out like falling for
you know their lies or not their lies
but like the way they play the story
because they do they do die but the way
you tell the story of like oh they might
be like spider-man killed me you're the
spider-man on my
universe or whatever earth killed me but
i like that it would lead to like a real
on foot conflict with doctor strange and
peter like there's something that sounds
extremely exciting about like strange
versus peter yeah well i mean i can see
from yeah for that purpose
yeah yeah from the footage we've seen
and also this speculation seems like
yeah you could have easily peter and
strange at odds pretty early on and that
becoming a big complication to
everything this scene is funny on the
train now looks a lot more like oh damn
strange is really trying to like get
spider-man basically and bring him back
to reality yeah because when we first
saw the trailer i was like what's going
on there yeah yeah first i was like ooh
adventure and now i'm like oh no he's
just trying to trap him from what we get
in the trailer it looks absolutely
outstanding i think it's gonna blow a
lot of people's minds watching this in
imax there's also a big chaser it's
clear that strange doesn't mind throwing
everything he can including uncharted 2
directly at him in order to stop him
breaking the multiverse strange clearly
catches up to peter
pushes his astral projection out of his
body which is also something that the
ancient one did to the incredible hulk
now from what strange says about double
lives i kind of get the feeling that
peter might actually be attempting to
flip back and forth between mj knowing
who he is and also forgetting that's
great for any guy in her relationship
yeah yeah she's mad at me flip
huh who are you
you want to go out
you're cute all right she's back into me
flip back on
potentially this spell broke reality and
him constantly doing this might be why
strange says the things that he does
about living two lives you also see what
could potentially be miles morales
mother and if you cast your mind back to
the title reveal you'll remember that
the surrounding lines looked a lot like
the island puerto rico so it could be
teasing his introduction here really
shots include the upgraded iron spider
which carries a slightly different
design to what it had in infinity war to
me this looks more in line with the
civil war version that was in the comics
but they've also made it at least line
up with what's come before now if we
look at the happy birthday storyline it
actually culminates with peter fighting
his entire oaks gallery across a number
of timelines this obviously lends itself
to the concept of no way home and i
would definitely recommend checking out
that book if you want some comics that
the movie will probably pull from okay
at the end of it strange gives peter
parker a present and he opens it to find
that it actually brings uncle ben back
to him for a few moments the pair talk
about his life and have a really amazing
conversation like that
yeah
no not me not me though i'm solid as
[ __ ] me now another interesting aspect
of the novel is that it ends with doctor
strange realizing that by breaking the
multiverse he's caused a lot of problems
in the magical world it very much teases
that he'll be facing off against several
sorcerers and potentially this could be
what happens
in the multiverse of madness we'll all
be part of the same storyline i think it
makes a lot of sense judging from the
way that the comic ends that you'll be
going toe-to-toe with her though we
don't know if a definite weather wonder
is going to be a villain i actually
think that you will and yeah i'd love to
see the scarlet witch go ahead ahead
with strange
i would love it too marvel and sony
weren't kidding when they said that this
would be tom holland's end game and it's
the culmination of several franchises
and films that started out 20 years ago
there's a lot resting on its shoulders
but i fully trust everyone on board with
the project to deliver something big and
bombastic this is definitely the best
movie since end game for me and outside
of the batman there's nothing that i'm
as hyped for i mean yeah this is
spider-man's end game in every way and
then they've really i think they've
properly prepped for this like setting
up multiverse and the guys into what if
sony doing uh spider-man into the
spider-verse having multiple spider-man
live-action all right
it's coming back to mind the sony
president being like believe it or not
we actually have a plan i'm like i can
kind of see
shouldn't have doubted you it's amazing
man i like i'm so excited for it because
all those spider-man movies are pulling
from were massive so yeah yeah this is
this is so exciting it's so special and
yeah i'm just so hyped after checking
out this first trailer for the film the
action is great the soundtrack is great
the ominous feeling and be careful what
you wish for tone works really well and
it reminds us that peter parker never
has it easy overall i'm super hyped and
yeah december can't come soon enough
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the trailer so make sure you comment
below and let me know well done paul
it's got up so fast seriously so fast
jeez i'm so impressed man
congratulations man can't wait for this
by this point by the time we're done
filming this i'm going to assume this
video is trending go to youtube already
knowing you man get a heavy spoiler
shirt yeah man can't wait for this
guys subscribe hit that bell click that
like button and we'll catch you guys
soon
you